alors depuis le 23 juillet c'est le
retour des perséides dans tout
l'hémisphère nord la célèbre pluie
annuelle d'étoilés filantes connaîtra à
partir de ce soir son record d'activité
à la plus grande joie des amateurs
d'astronomie bien sûr alors que leurs
activités sont d'ailleurs prévues à
l'astrolab du parc national du mont
mégantic
pour en parler nous recevons ses lacets
giga et coordonnateur scientifique à
l'astrolab du parc national du monde du
mont mégantic alors bonjour monsieur
bonjour vous leur dites nous comment ça
se profile cette année est ce que les
conditions d'observation sont bonnes
pour cours des prochains jours
ça dépend toujours un peu de notre sens
de l'émerveillement personnel je vous
dirai donc la réponse est oui mais il
faut effectivement cette année faire une
petite précaution oratoire au sens où la
lune sera très présente cette année donc
question de calibrer les attentes c'est
sûr que le nombre d'étoilés filantes à
l'heure qu'on pourra voir sera inférieur
à ce qu'on peut voir lorsque la lune
n'est pas présent ce qui évidemment une
part dont on ne veut pas dire que les
spectacles on voudra pas la peine au
contraire donc normalement la pluie
d'étoilés filantes des perséides on
parle d'un tour des toiles filantes à
l'heure qui frôle la centaine une armée
sans lune donc là avec la lune peut-être
que ce sera une trentaine les météores
les étoiles les plus brillantes seront
toujours visibles donc c'est amplement
suffisant pour passer une belle soirée
sous les étoiles et ça c'est parce que
la lune fait beaucoup et même beaucoup
de lumière c'est ce que vous êtes
exactement à la lune et une scion et
même une sorte de pollution lumineuse
naturel si on veut donc son éclat qui se
diffuse dans l'atmosphère vos masques et
les étoiles filantes les plus faibles
mais encore une fois les étoiles les
plus brillantes étoiles filantes les
plus brillants sont nettement visibles
si on a la chance de s'éloigner un peu
de la pollution lumineuse on risque
d'avoir un beau spectacle pendant les
pendant les prochaines jours mais ce
giga parlez-nous des activités qui
auront lieu justement à l'astrolabe
qu'est ce qui est prévu cette année pour
les gens qui souhaitent les voir ces
belles étoiles on est tellement heureux
cette année deux enfants et revenir à
une formule traditionnelle si on veut
pour les percées de mont mégantic au
coeur de la première réserve
internationale de ciel étoilé avec
toutes nos installations nous ça va
devoir dédié au public donc les gens
sont invités à venir passer à la nuit
avec nous a invités à amener leurs
chaises leur matelas de sol et à compter
les étoiles filantes via des télescopes
sur place des présentations d activité
sévèrement grande fête des étoiles au
mont mégantic mais aussi partout
ailleurs au québec les clubs
d'astronomie amateur ou s'ils organisent
des activités donc pour ce qui est du
mont mégantic les activités avec les
réservations sont déjà complets pour
accéder au sommet mais il reste beaucoup
de place sans réservation à la base pour
les gens qui veulent venir profiter du
spectacle avec une écurie à savoir les
personnes c'est dû à quoi exactement
monsieur giguère oui c'est une question
c'est belle étoile filante le convoi
présidentiel c'est impressionnant mais
souvent en fait savoir que c'est causé
par des particules de la taille d'un
grain de poussière de grains de sable
d'un petit poids total est donc ce sont
de très petites particules qui ont été
semées en fait par une commune une
comète qui répond au doux nom de la
comète swift tuttle du nom de ses
découvreurs qui fait le tour de la terre
en une centaine un peu plus qu'une
centaine d'années et qui revient de
temps en temps enrichir cette traînée
cette rivière de poussière que
simulation veut qu'elle sème la comète
lors de son passage autour du soleil
parce qu'elle se désagrège un peu elles
font un peu et tout au long de sa
trajectoire il ya cette rivière
d'auxerre que ce mec-là que la terre
traverse chaque année au mois d'août à
peu près à la même date et il faut
savoir aussi que d'autres pluie
d'étoilés filantes des perséides sont
les plus connus il arrive au bon moment
de l'année c'est parmi les plus intenses
mais il ya aussi les géminides et
quadrantides de l'hiver aussi donc les
personnes ne sont pas les ce n'est pas
la seule pluie d'étoilés filantes dans
la nuit est ce que c'est quand même
possible de les de les voir de les
observer si on est en ville parce qu'on
sait que la pollution lumineuse le cache
un peu la vue de ces étoiles filantes
mais quand même y en a plusieurs dans
oui c'est tout à fait possible faut être
un peu plus patient parfois donc dans
évidemment parce que on va en voir un
peu moins mais si on est patient on
risque fort d'avoir une traversé le ciel
si on est capable de se trouver un parc
un endroit où l'horizon est un peu plus
dégagé donc pas trop de gros luminaires
à côté pas trop de grazia non plus et de
s'étendre sur le dos pour vraiment
observer la plus grande partie de ciel
possible au dessus de nos têtes et des
cantons chance avec nos amis nos
familles nos proches bien en garde les
yeux sur le sur le ciel
pour être sûr de prendre mon crime on a
vu là dans certaines municipalités dans
le haut saint françois la population est
appelée à éteindre leur éclairage
extérieur en sus ce qu'on demande pour
être capable de bien voir ces étoiles
filantes est ce que à l'astrolabe on
envisage de faire un appel général dans
le futur pour que ça se fasse ailleurs
on fait un peu partout au québec
finalement
oui c'est une super belle initiative qui
a été pris par les gens du haut saint
françois du trech très très content
c'est une très belle idée et oui il ya
des discussions actuellement pour les
cours étant d'éventuellement
l'initiative on sait que les les
perséides c'est un peu la fête des
étoiles c'est presque dans la culture
maintenant au québec d'observer les
étoiles donc c'est un très bon moment
pour sensibiliser la population
au spectacle ciels étoilés qui est
magnifique pendant les périodes bien sûr
mais qui est magnifique à l'année et
spectacle qui menace est aujourd'hui en
raison de la pollution lumineuse et
c'est aussi une opportunité pour montrer
qu'il ya moyen dans ce que l'on voit
était au complet mais qu'on peut réduire
notre éclairage et concilier les besoins
de sécurité les besoins et la présence
quand même du spectacle du territoire et
donc oui à suivre pour pour l'an
prochain alors sébastien giguère de
l'astrolabe je vous souhaite une pluie
d'étoilés filantes merci d'avoir été
avec nous ce matin
merci à vous pour voir nos émissions en
entier rendez vous sur la chaîne ici et
redit
[Musique]